>> WE PLAYED THAT SONG
YESTERDAY.
I WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> AMERICA IS SUFFERING FROM
MAJOR CYBER ATTACKS AND EXPERTS
SAY HACKERS ARE JUST GETTING
STARTED.
THE PIPELINE AND A MAJOR MEAT
SUPPLIER WERE TARGETED AND
A CYBER CRIMINAL COULD MESS WITH
YOUR COMMUNITY.
THE NEW YORK CITY TRANSIT
AUTHORITY REPORTED A BREACH THAT
HAPPENED IN APRIL.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS DOWNPLAYING
THESE CYBER THREATS.
>> THEY HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PUT IN PLACE MEASURES TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN CYBER SECURITY.
YOU COULD GO TRACKDOWN THE CYBER
CRIMINALS IN RUSSIA AND HAVE
A GOOD CHAT WITH THEM.
>> SHE IS SO SARCASTIC ABOUT
SERIOUS ISSUES.
THAT REMINDS ME OF YOU, JESSICA.
YOU HAVE A THEORY.
THE REASON WHY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOWNPLAYING
THESE ASSAULTS IS BECAUSE THEY
ARE UP-PLAYING A WORD I INVENTED
OTHER ISSUES.
FOR EXAMPLE,ING THE CLIMATE
CRISIS SHOULD TAKE UP 50% OF
YOUR ATTENTION AND THE REMAINING
50% GOES TO EVIL WHITE ARMIES OF
SUPREMACY.
SO YOUR BRAIN IS FILLED WITH
EVIL WHITE MEN AND WIND MILLS.
THAT'S MY THEORY.
JESSICA, YOU HAVE 10 SECONDS TO
RESPOND.
>> DO YOU REMEMBER ON REDEYE THE
GAME WHERE YOU COULD PUSH
A BUTTON AND A LIBERAL GOT TO
TALK FOR 7 SECONDS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I CAN BORROW THAT?
>> NO.
I DISAGREE AND I AM STICKING TO
MY STORY.
WE WERE TALKING THIS THE
GREENROOM THAT LEON FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HE WAS ON
WITH NEIL CAVUTO.
HE GAVE A SPEECH IN 2012 TALKING
ABOUT HOW WARFARE WILL BE FOUGHT
ON THE CYBER FRONT.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT OBAMA AND
BIDEN TOOK SERIOUSLY.
OUR SELECTION SECURITY IS FRONT
AND CENTER FOR ALL OF US.
THEY THINK THEY ARE WORKING WITH
THE PENTAGON TO STOP HAVING
BREACHES THAT AFFECT EVERYBODY.
>> SHE SAID IT'S A PRIVATE
SECTOR ISSUE.
>> SHE RESPECTS THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY ARE NOT
WORKING TOGETHER.
WITH APPLE AND OPENING UP
A KILLER'S PHONE.
>> WE DON'T HAVE PHONES LIKE
THAT ANYMORE.
>> LIBERALS DO.
>> OKAY.
[LAUGHING].
EVIL SHANNON BREAM.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THEY ARE TARGETING OUR
COMMUTE.
THAT'S PRETTY SERIOUS.
NO ONE WANTS TO GET STUCK ON
A SUBWAY.
IMAGINE WHAT THAT IS LIKE.
STUCK IN A NEW YORK CITY SUBWAY
TRAIN.
>> YOU ARE DEAD.
>> YES, YOU ARE DEAD.
>> YOU DON'T WANT THAT DURING
SUMMER TIME.
IT WAS 4,000 DEGREES AND SMELLED
LIKE DEAD RATS.
IT'S NOT GOOD?
>> I FOUND OUT A RABBIT HOLE
READING ABOUT THIS STUFF.
ONE BY IS A RANSOM-WARE
NEGOTIATOR.
HE SAID THIS IS A BIGGER PROBLEM
THAN YOU THINK.
WHAT DO YOU TELL A HOSPITAL YOU
CAN'T GIVE CHEMOTHERAPY TODAY
BECAUSE WE CAN'T NEGOTIATE.
THEY HAVE SCRIPTS WHO SAY THIS
IS WHAT YOU SAY IN THE FIRST
OFFER.
IT'S INSANE HOW MUCH IS
HAPPENING.
WE ONLY HEAR ABOUT THE STUFF
ABOUT THE PIPELINES AND THE
BEEF.
DON'T MESS WITH THE CHICKENS.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT?
THE ONLY WAY AMERICANS WILL CARE
ABOUT THIS IS IF THEIR PRIVATE
SNCHLTIO
SNCHLTION -- INFORMATION IS
BLACK MAILED.
IF IT'S ONE-ON-ONE AND ONE EVER
THESE FREE AGENCY SAYS 10 GRAND
OR 30 GRAND OR WE DROP THIS
STUFF.
THAT WILL HAPPEN.
>> YES, HUNTER'S STUFF IS
ALREADY OUT THERE AND THEY SAID
THAT WAS FAKE NEWS.
>> GOOD THING BIDEN IS WORKING
SO HARD -- ACTUALLY HE TOOK THE
DAY OFF.
>> IT'S THE FIRST LADY'S
BIRTHDAY.
>> HE IS THE PRESIDENT.
I DON'T TAKE THURSDAYS OFF.
HE IS RIDING BIKES IN DELAWARE.
HE DOESN'T KNOW THERE IS A CYBER
WARE.
THEY HAVE BIG BEEF AND BIG OIL
AND JEN PSAKI SAID IT'S THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THEY CAN FIGHT
THE WAR.
IT'S ON THE HOMELAND.
YOU ARE TELLING THE TERRORISTS
THESE ARE TARGETS THE PRESIDENT
WON'T --
>> WHAT IF THEY BOMBED A PRIVATE
SECTOR BUSINESS?
>> THEY WENT AFTER MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
DEMOCRATS WON'T HAVE ANYWHERE TO
GO.
THEY HAVE TO BRING BACK THE BUSH
DOCTRINE.
YOU HOLD PUTIN ACCOUNTABLE.
BIDEN WILL GO TO SWITZERLAND AND
SIT DOWN WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN AT
THE SUMMIT AND SAY KNOCK IT OFF.
BIDEN SAYS PUTIN KNOCK IT OFF
AND CNN WILL AT A BIDEN IS TOUGH
ON RUSSIA.
NO.
BIDEN HAS TO DO SOMETHING TO
RUSSIA TO MAKE RUSSIA FEEL PAIN
SO THEY DON'T DO IT AGAIN.
>> THERE ARE COMPANIES OUT THERE
THAT COULD -- A PRIVATE SECTOR
THAT COULD PREVENT THESE THINGS
FROM HAPPENING?
DO THEY HAVE BACKUPS FOR
COMPANIES IN CASE THEY ARE
COMPROMISED?
>> YES, IT IS ON THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THEY SPEND MONEY ON TECHNOLOGY
THAT CAN YIELD A PROFIT.
THEY DON'T SPEND MONEY ON
SOMETHING THEY CAN'T QUANTIFY
NET INCOME WHICH IS SAFETY.
THIS JOE BIDEN'S OPPORTUNITY TO
BE A BAD ASS.
ALL HE HAS TO DO IS COME OUT.
I WROTE A TINY LITTLE SPEECH FOR
HIM.
IF YOU ATTACK THE UNITED STATES
IN ANY VITAL INFRASTRUCTURE OR
SERVICES, THERE IS NO SAFE PLACE
ON THIS PLANET FOR YOU.
WE WILL COME FOR YOU AND WE WILL
KILL YOU.
IF YOU ARE A PIPELINE, AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROL, IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
IF A NATION IS BEHIND THE CYBER
CRIME WE WILL TREAT THIS AS AN
ACT OF WAR.
AN INDIVIDUAL WE WILL TREAT YOU
AS A TERRORIST.
THERE IS NOWHERE TO HIDE.
BIDEN IS BUSY EATING CAKE AND
HIDING IN THE WHITE